There are many times when you need to add
stitches to the edge of your knitting.
A pattern may read "cast on 20
stitches on the right side".
Using a cast-on rag makes this process
easier by giving you scrap
knitting to hang weight.
Cast-on rag is reusable and it can also
be used is for starting your knitting
saving Scrap Yarn. To create a cast-on rag,
use a strong, tightly twisted yarn.
You'll be knitting a diagonal piece.
Start at the left edge of your needlebed
and cast on four to five stitches.
Knit a few rows and end
with your carriage on the right.
On the left side, decrease one stitch.
I'm using a two-pronged tool.
Use whatever is comfortable for you.
Put the empty needle out of work
on the right side.
Pull one needle into work.
Knit two rows.
You'll notice that a loop is
formed over the new needle.
This is the key to the caston rag.
Continue to decrease left and increase
right until the piece
is the desired length.
The knitting will travel across the bed
and you may need to take all the stitches
off and rehang them on the left side again
to continue making the rag longer.
If you crochet.
Another quick way of making a reusable
cast on rag is with crochet.
Simply work a piece with smooth
yarn the width you need.
Double crochet, single crochet,
whatever works for your yarn.
Hang the edges of the crochet row
on the needles, knit one row of ravel
cord and then use this to hang weight.
You can now either cast
on with the garment yarn over the ravel
cord or just start knitting
for a provisional caston.
When you remove the ravel cord,
you'll have the crochet rag
to use over and over again.
If I'm only casting on a few stitches
and I'm in a hurry, I'll confess that I've
resorted to using a swatch
that's lying around.
I hang the edge of the swatch.
On the needles, hang some weights
and knit a row of ravel I cord.
I can then begin working right away.
With the garment yarn without having to.
Find my cast on rag.
If you have knitting on the machine
and you are adding stitches,
use the cast-on rag. End with the carriage
and the yarn from the yarn feeder
on the right,
hang one loop on each needle as needed.
Hang weights also as needed.
Manually knit a row of ravel cord.
Then, using the yarn from the yarn feeder,
cast on the new needles using the method
of your choice.
Knit across all the needles and continue
knitting as directed in your pattern.
When you finish knitting,
remove the ravel cord
and set aside the cast-on and rag.
And you'll see you have a very neat edge.